six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number that is the
one and only number for live calls and
we are taking calls let's go next to the
six one seven number maybe somebody from
here in Boston caller from six one seven
tell us who you are and go right ahead
hey David
yes hi yeah Boston actually the one that
took your tuna sandwich a tuna salad
sandwich order yesterday that's right
yes sir remind me your name is yeah my
doctor Oscar right yeah I met Oscar
yesterday or earlier in the week Pat I
went in and I had a completely not don't
say where by the way Oscar I don't want
people show I was I showed up and I had
a completely non vegan lunch and Oscar
was fine with it and he said he's a fan
of the show and he wants live calls to
stay so yeah what's going on Oscar hi in
the sense that my my parents would
pretty much traditionally liberal or
since like the establishment type they
do some shows my ideas are progressive
policies but I've also had some friends
who are very very conservative like you
know libertarian types
my question is whenever I talk to my
parents about politics they always seem
to be spoke to you know the MSNBC CNN
talking point where they'll just go to
Trump Russia or you know they'll just
keep saying things about and they and
they share that same Haitian of trumpet
I do of course but I was just wondering
what the best way you think talk to
those kind of establishment Democrats
people who do share you know pretty much
all all of the same progressive policy
ideas we just are caught up in this kind
of MSNBC assumption bubble yeah so
here's the approach rather than telling
them that they're focusing on stuff that
doesn't matter because Trump Rush is a
real story right we cover the story but
it's not the only story that's going on
you want to use that and build on it
right so you want to say I completely
agree with you on these issues these are
really important issues and I also want
to let you know
that here's these five other things that
you're not going to hear about on MSNBC
and CNN that are just as important and
once Trump rushes resolved we're gonna
have to deal with right the fact that
wages haven't gone up but inequality has
or whatever issue right the environment
we're going backwards on the environment
whatever the case may be use the fact
that they're already sort of on the
right side to actually pull them into
other issues they may not know about
yeah that makes sense yeah I mean I feel
like yes you do you think I get so
caught up in nothing where they they
just don't want to they don't want they
don't have the time can give their
thoughts to those issues you know they
care about this so yeah that's why you
got to be ready with what er what are
the issues like if you could only give
them one or two ish new issues to think
about what are those two going it's
going to be you should you have to be
ready with you right I think I do do
that because I mentioned you know you
know love the quality and on the
environment like you said right but I
think I feel like at the same time they
they just keep watching you know I'm at
NBC and they just pay attention to
Russia
it's my family so it's a little
difficult but it feels like you should
never get anywhere brought up yeah well
it sounds like a whole situation over
there but it sounds like you're managing
it yeah pretty well Oscar thanks good
glad you got through I know you've been
you've been trying for a while yeah
thank you
all right take care great to hear from
Oscar from Boston yeah I met met Oscar
yesterday okay that's gonna do it for
live calls I wish I had more time I just
don't
I apologize to the dozen people that are
holding but we will take calls again and
it'll be great when we do that I can
promise you